Let's go instead to Tyler from St. Louis.
Tyler, you're on the air.
Hello, David, um, so.
I don't know exactly the subject of everything,
but.
I was wondering, is there anything to the
arguments that universal health care would
lead to lower quality of health care?
Well, that's what I tend to hear, but I never
complain, never explain causal relationships.
They're the best the best of the best stuff
I've read about.
This is from the late Ouvea Rhinehart, who
wrote that basically imagine a triangle.
You're familiar with a triangle, I'm sure,
and you know that it has three corners.
Does that make sense?
Mm hmm.
The three corners of health care are cost,
quality and access, and that no matter what
system you support, you are basically picking
a midpoint between those three.
So, for example, if you want to make it really
cheap and give it to everybody, quality is
going to go down now.
It could still be better quality than we have
and we might still be spending more, you know,
like we spend a lot.
So this is just theoretical on building the
theoretical framework.
So if you want to give it to everybody and
make it cheap, there's going to be some sacrifice
in terms of quality, all else being equal.
If you want to make it cheap and really good,
then to some degree you have to restrict access,
you understand.
So everything is kind of a balancing act.
And so when we talk about universal health
care, if you want it to be universal and you
want it to be really good, it's just going
to be more expensive.
Now, a lot of people will hear me say this
and they'll say, David, that's not true.
Look at how much we spend on medical billing
and there's profit motive.
And then there's all these levels of bureaucracy.
And then because some people don't have health
insurance, hospitals raise prices and make
them artificially high.
That's all completely true.
That's absolutely and completely true.
I'm just saying, all else being equal, if
you want to make it high quality and available
to everybody, it's going to cost some money.
And it may be it may be a reasonable amount
of money.
For example, I would be OK with it being expensive
if we've actually eliminated all of the waste
and the bureaucracy and all of these things.
It's just as a decision as a society that
we have to make.
And so that's the sort of triangle you have
to think of.
It's all just picking a point between those
three corners and saying, here is where we
want to be.
OK, thank you.
And by the way, if you ever end up in St.
Louis, make sure to try St. Louis style pizza.
Is that a thing or is that a joke?
Well, it's the thing.
It's really good.
What it what what are the characteristics?
So it has its own we have our own cheese called
Proval, OK?
And it's like it's like a mix of provolone
and Swiss and American cheese.
People say it's an acquired taste, but I don't
know.
I've always liked it.
Well, I'm up for trying it.
Yeah.
And then it's cut.
It's cut into squares.
And what about that?
And it's got a very it's got a very thin,
like cracker like crust.
OK.
All right.
Well, the next time I'm in St. Louis, I will
check that out.
All right, see you.
All right, my friend, thank you
for the call, appreciate it.
Let's go to I think this is either Alexa or
Alexander or Alexandra in Los Angeles.
Alex in Los Angeles, you're on the air.
And Alex, Alexandra, whoever is gone,